[Music]
today on 6a football we are coming to
you live from the historic Jordan's Big
Ten pub in Madison Wisconsin there are I
feel like there's five hundred people
standing right behind me guys million
people around million we could fill the
mall right now a million it's gonna be
so much fun we were presented today by
mercs cheese guys and I am about to dig
in sharp cheddar spreadable cheese and
they brought us pretzels which they know
me there's a football there's gonna be
some beers flowing as soon as the show
is over and that's gonna be amazing
makes you a little hungry today so we
have a lot to talk about our guy Adam
Kramer from Bleacher Report the best
damn college football writer in the
country is gonna be joining us to talk
about Jonathan Taylor we're gonna do
live draft on draft the stick to
football hall of fame is here with a new
leader I'm very excited about that for
them it's gonna be your divided a good
day for us but guys I hate to say it it
was a bad day for someone on Friday how
you gonna get fired on a Friday Antonio
Brown come on man yeah it's Friday you
ain't got no job
he doesn't know huh I love this move
though I love it by the Patriots it was
a move that I thought was going to come
I probably expected a little bit more
than one week but I think they did right
with so many allegations you can't have
that going in and on in your locker room
it's about time hopefully this is the
last time we have to talk about Antonio
Brown and I know Bill Belichick is
notorious for press conferences where he
looks frustrated by questions I thought
it was on a different level on Friday
morning it looked like this was coming
he was so tired of just answering the
questions about a B and I think listen
does New England really need him no I
know he's great but do they need him it
never looks like I'm stopped
they've won a lot of Super Bowls without
a B and there's a good chance that win
at least the other against the Dolphins
he had what four catches on eight
targets they will be just fine without a
Antonio Brown I need you to buy
subtraction I tweeted it I don't want to
talk about him anymore but I know we
have to everyone's asking hey where's he
gonna go I don't think he does number
one the NFL's gonna take its time
investigating this yeah and some people
said just put him on the exempt list
here's a fun fact you can't if a
player's not on a team you can't put
them on the exempt list he's just gonna
be unemployed and you know what we
we went through this with Tyree kill
we've gone through with other players
maybe it all turns out that this was
false but until that comes out we can't
think about him as a pro player anymore
like it for what however you feel that a
B as a player if he can make your team
better it's just not gonna happen
and for those asking about the XFL
already mat so you tweet this right away
they might have a strict character
problem they won't wear him in I don't
think he'll have yeah exactly I don't
know about to play a record you cannot
play the XFL and a B has a record and
and another thing I'm gonna rant I guess
this goes back to his time at Central
Michigan this is who he was in college
it was that's why he felled you the
sixth round of the draft it wasn't
because he wasn't good it was because of
character so we're seeing that come to
light I know a lot of people want to say
oh it was the vantes perfect hit no it
was oh the perfect hit him at Central
Michigan like right this guy didn't play
week 17 of the Steelers game that was
way before any vantes perfect stuff I
think no it's been a long history with
him and I think now that it's just it's
in the limelight everybody's looking at
it he's putting it on Instagram on
social media so now everybody's just
aware yeah let's transition there was a
game Friday night if you missed it a
pac-12 heater Utah ranked number 10
facing an uneven USC team someone's been
very up and down all year we all liked
you talked to win the pac-12 didn't like
OSC didn't like USC well us he's on
their third quarterback and guys he
might actually be a good as was their
number two quarterback slovis who got
injured Friday night when leaky foe too
broke him in half oh absolutely
him to the turf in the NFL that's a flag
and a fine but at college it's like oh
that's cool let's do that full body
weight thing and when you have 320
pounds landing on you I think
everybody's under your sternum yeah
hopefully gets healthy I didn't get to
hear what actually happened with him
wish the best best for him you don't
want anybody to get hurt and on the Utah
side exact Moss got hurt which really
limits them he only had I believe six
carries last night for 20 yards but the
standout of the game was wide receiver
Michael Pittman junior whose dad had the
best arms in football he's like he's
your idol no he actually is yes Friday
Carmichael Pipo days with Michael
Pittman and his son tearing it up ten
catches last night for 232 yards and a
touchdown we need to get him in the
conversation as one of the best receiver
prospects in the nation yeah and I think
this is what happens when you put
real athlete in that air raid office who
saw it a long time ago with michael
crabtree and how these guys are able to
dominate if you have a good big target
out there that can move it's very easy
to get them the ball in this spread
offense I like what USC is doing I wish
they could do it more consistently
because we saw him against BYU and they
look like total crap out there and now
you watch them against Utah which is one
of the best defenses in the nation and
they tear them up they torture for 232
yards this conference just has a habit
of tearing each other apart and they
really get a team in the playoff because
of that I know they will it's exciting
for the conference but for the playoff X
expectations it's gone do you guys think
and I know my answer but I'll play host
and ask do you think this saves clay
Hilton's job no not yet I think there
are a lot of big games on that schedule
so far and you have to do more than beat
Utah I don't think that comes into the
season as this is one of our must dues
even though it Utah's very good what
sucks the O'Connor is they've eliminated
themselves from the playoff now
Stanford's out Washington's out you know
now you have Utah out organs out with a
loss you can't have one loss and on the
pac-12 I'll make the playoffs you know
well it's over so it is it exciting you
knew he was maybe a little bit but for
your national championship expectations
it crushes them and then you talk about
USC they're gonna have a tough team
against Washington so like Melo said
they're not out of it yet in terms of
surviving there if you're that coaching
staff back to Pittman though I think
what's really exciting about him and
correct me if I'm wrong he's senior bowl
eligible he s senior ball and that's a
place where there'll be some good
corners but that's a place where he can
go shine all right we don't get a lot of
top 50 top 75 players as wide receivers
there I think that's gonna mean Colin
Johnson being there great huge big guys
you know I think it will change and I
know our guy Jim naggy a conversation
we've had a lot is you know T Higgins
can't go to the Senior Bowl Michael
Pittman junior can see do prove you're
better Jerry Chu Han can and rerun see
actually is going to graduate in
December Judy and rugs are going to be
Senior Bowl eligible they won't I love
Jim they're not going to senior work
long as they pass the basket weaving or
whatever they're taking this semester at
Alabama they're gonna be senior white
shake some hands
hello yeah would nick saban know they're
gonna be one-on-ones on the sidelines
next to us you imagine if they did
though I'll play devil's advocate for
gym if you get rugs out there with these
corners trying to jam him Brice Hall has
no chance he cannot get his hands Ron
man Henry rug so it would probably be a
good move for a guy like rugs
I think Jerry's solidified himself as
probably top five yeah but you get rugs
out there below and past these other
corners that actually might really help
his draft stock yeah I would love a seat
when he comes out rug - we were talking
to our guy Kramer last night who's gonna
join us in our third segment he thinks
that he could around a four to one oh
yeah I believe it I do I usually don't
buy into these now I think he gets on
what you saw naggy tweet out a while ago
I don't know if you guys saw that they
they timed him at the junior days and
like this is a guy that's gonna run a
fort - but he's already running two for
two when he goes and fix his guitar in
your explain every fast yeah he's he's
gonna be one of the fastest players
we've ever seen I don't know if they
have prop bets ready to go a Caesar's
Palace but if they can find one Henry
rugs is gonna run the fastest 40 all
right boys let's take a break when we
come back we're gonna give you our big
game breakdown live from Madison
Wisconsin this is stick to football
they'll roll right into it yeah we'll
just keep going all right all right here
we go three two one it is big game break
down time boys presented by Marx and I'm
like I'm drooling staring at this sharp
cheddar box and drown me in a bowl of
pretzels you'll see it on YouTube it
looks good like I want to eat it I don't
want it to stare at it it looks amazing
I'm gonna destroy that I'm gonna put
some on Conor and there's going to be
some taste testing if the Box wrote but
I would do it on the podcast which is
great one of the first rules of
podcasting they told us was don't eat we
break those rules pretty much all the
time right I haven't drank beers in a
while on the podcast so we're gonna
bring that back on Thursday nights right
yeah I think that needs to come back on
Thursdays right let's get into the game
today
number 13 Wisconsin number 10 11 11
Michigan there we go whose rankings am I
looking at
apparently right now they don't matter
Michigan they don't matter it is
overcast today we're expecting some rain
a little bit later that's the
information you only get on the ground
fellows and I do think that that could
play into this
I've said it all week when we've been
asked about the game job that Taylor has
35 carries issue that's a very low
number for him he also just had the week
off Michigan and Wisconsin were both on
a bike to me this signals conspiracy
theory Jonathan Taylor's gonna touch the
ball about thirty five times together
yeah it has to I think when you look at
like keys to victory that's what
Wisconsin has to do control the clock
keep the ball in your offenses hands you
don't want to give a quarterback like
Shay Patterson time to score points not
with those receivers some with you I
think that Jonathan Taylor he's going to
take at least 25 touches unless this
game gets out of hand because when
you're giving him the ball I mean he'll
there's a chance he could go 10 carries
100 yards and this game is just done for
in the second quarter by they got to get
Jonathan Taylor involved it's Wisconsin
so you know they would you just feel
like your game sorry Connor if Michigan
scores first the game is changed a lot
because the Michigan could get
comfortable Jack cone is it's okay but
we haven't really seen Wisconsin be a
team that can play from behind I don't
think so
I'd like the first team that scores
today has a good chance to win yeah for
all the Jonathan Taylor talk I think the
conversation then pivots the jack cone
so I think when you look at him he's
been very good this year he's not
turning the football over but this is
the first real test we're going to get
some defense they'll be ready for him I
think you see way better player than
Hornibrook already so that's a good sign
I know Arnie brings awful about when it
comes on this finally might be a team
where the quarterback isn't just running
them into the ground yeah where you
don't have to run the ball to protect
your quarterback and say holy crap if he
throws the ball it's probably going to
be an interception now you don't have to
worry about that so much but this will
be their first true test coming into
conference play it's a huge game
obviously if you're watching this on
youtube you see all the fans that are
here Michigan knows this is a huge game
for them the Wisconsin fans they're out
to prove that they can really contend in
the Big Ten and I think they will do
that by the end of the day yeah let's go
game predictions I know we've given them
on the Friday show if anything's changed
for you guys I'm still picking Wisconsin
I did not bet on this game
didn't go great the line was three and a
half as of this morning I don't know if
it's moved but and there were some big
bets placed on Wisconsin like huge bets
but I just don't feel comfortable trying
to attack that spread but I think
Wisconsin does win the biggest surprise
for me maybe is that you know these are
generally two schools that play great
defense and these defenses are not that
great I think Michigan is really
struggled to replace all the guys they
lost last year I mean and then for the
Michigan offense listen we have to talk
about Shay Patterson and how
inconsistent he has been even when he's
been serviceable there seems to be a
lack of confidence in his play and in
the coaching staff yeah I just talked
about how many Michigan fans are here
and I asked Mike how do you feel about
the game why are you nervous coming into
it they said yeah you just you can't
trust Shay Patterson that's coming from
Michigan fans it's coming from us
looking at it as a college football
perspective and a draft perspective the
best quarterback on the field today
might be the backup for Michigan yeah it
really might be Dylan McCaffrey and I
think it's tough because Michigan has
the weapons around him for this to be a
good offense they've great wide
receivers we know that all three of them
can be impact kind of players so when
healthy of course I took Wisconsin as
well covering that three and a half line
was really really tough because I don't
think this is gonna be a scenario like
last year mission showed up at Ohio
State and then got run over I don't
think they're gonna get steamrolled here
but I can't see them winning this game
yet Jim Harbaugh wins these games a lot
but at the end of the day I just think
Wisconsin's the tougher football team I
think there's a more reliable football
team on offense and there at home so
that's why they should get the win our
official mercs
big game preview prediction all of us
take on Wisconsin sorry Michigan fans
we're in Wisconsin and they're given us
cheese but I also think Jonathan Taylor
gets it done today all right let's take
a break when we come back we're gonna
bring in our guy Adam Kramer who just
wrote an amazing story on Jonathan
Taylor I'm gonna talk to him about that
and everything else going on in the
world of college football
Jordan's big 10 has been amazing to us
today definitely recommend this if you
ever just want even if you're not a
wisconsin fan just come to this place
fun do you like football and beer and
fun this is it speaking of football beer
and fun that's basically Adam Kramer
that's if I had to use three words to
describe Adam Kramer that would be it
this is this is on brand like this
weather is held up temperature is it is
perfect this is awesome you guys got a
good gig this is your first football
tailgate that's what you do this is like
don't tell anyone that this is it don't
tell your boss you have a heart you have
a little like an arsenal of koozies it's
not small yeah I got a rework might be
our arrangement here yeah yeah we may be
we be a form and everyone else remote I
do want to ask though you just filed a
story about Jonathan Taylor that's
really must read people should go check
that out in the BR app but you and I
have talked a lot about him over
probably the last year as a pro prospect
as a college player do you feel like
he's he's being underrated almost like
it's 4,000 yards in two years he has a
chance to break Ron Danes record in
three years it wouldn't be crazy no it
wouldn't the numbers are stupid like the
numbers are like you knew he had great
numbers and when I met with him I handed
him a sheet of paper with his numbers
and I said what do you think of these
and it's like Herschel Walker
it's LaDainian Tomlinson and it was cool
to see him just big yeah you know I
probably could have doubled out and so
like the preconceived notion I have
naturally with these guys is like their
their system bags and I don't mean that
as like a negative it's just like you
plugged them in Melvin Gordon Montee
Ball James Michael SS Ron Dayne and then
you look at this dude and you're like no
this this guy's cut different and that
that was the part that when we talked
about yeah like even just sizing them up
and then talking to like the strength
coach and talking to people they're like
no man like this is a 4-3 kid who's 220
pounds that does crazy stuff and that's
what people forget to they think
Wisconsin running back system running
back to 20 well it's gonna be a big
bruiser he's a New Jersey state track
champion in the hundred I can't run a 20
in the hundred he's blazing fast too and
a lot of people they just kind of under
eight that and say yeah Wisconsin back
probably a big bruiser
what's crazy though this year is like I
write this story about him being like
the rushing champion and he's got three
receiving touchdowns - yeah and it's
like man you kind of teen teen the theme
of my story that I'm going but that's
like if he can do that I mean from an
NFL value standpoint just isn't overall
value like that's crazies he and he's
also like it he's different like he
talked to these kids
he's into jigsaw puzzles and he's into
hot yoga and he's into lame but he's cut
a little bit different so you talk to
him yeah I I can only imagine like what
Scout sit down with him and NFL people
they're gonna make oh dude I want like
this guy's this kind of hints at my
question then going into the story did
you come away with anything you didn't
expect when you came out of it finished
it up I think just how thoughtful he is
like this is a guy who is like a
psychology like it like he's like look
he's reading me like he was like sizing
Mia
so I'm asking him questions and he's not
deflecting but he's asking me questions
back and like that interaction you don't
know him like that okay especially with
a good bounce from a 21 year okay yeah
like so it was like I thought like I
thought about like the way I interview
people after this like oh did this dude
just size me up so I just love that like
there's just a depth to him and it's no
insult to a lot of the guys that you
cover you like hey man these guys are
all great good kids but there's like a
certain depth to him that like I have
not seen a lot of
kids did you ask him about the fumbles
because that is something that does get
brought up is him freshman year I think
it went to 8 somewhere he had 4 so far
so good this year but is it something
that he's aware of yes I mean that's
like that it's gotta be like the denied
I mean there's nothing like it's hard to
find them other than that like just the
amount of times he's carrying the ball
which was interesting to talk to him as
well like dude there work at your
they're maximizing Gary Henry yeah yeah
oh he's carrying the ball a ton and he
kind of loves it of course it's gonna
say it but the fun this stuff really the
only thing he could say is like yeah I'm
gonna fix it and we'll see I mean that
because if he can do that there's not
much anything could catch the ball mount
liked it
where's the the hole hit on me like
there's there's not many holes in this
game I'm really interested to see the
receiving stuff he's got any touchdowns
in a couple games if the receiving stuff
continues I think he already surpassed
his total yards from last year it's
crazy mad very fever yeah yeah that's
not did you I think you got the chance
to ask him because he's a New Jersey guy
what brought him to Wisconsin he escaped
Rutgers somehow so Sam Addison I'm from
Jersey originally he is from that far
from where I grew up and my uncle's had
very sad shitty Rutgers season tickets
for like 30 years
yeah I go home and it's like dude what
why so you think about Rutgers by the
way say Kuan Berkeley and and this dude
like in the same sort of right oh gosh
I'm Gary oh hey they lose a lot of great
writers so he wanted to go to Rutgers
like he really liked the friends family
loyalty growing up with the program once
thought about going to Harvard he's at
Harvard
two or three times I thought that was
something he was going to do which is
again like okay but then you you come
here like he didn't have like a crazy
list of offers Virginia Tech Boston
College like there were good offers but
then you look at this you're like okay
this is academics were huge for him
athletics there's not much better
balance in the country than miss Wright
I mean when you think of Stanford's
they're they're getting crushed by UCF
now this is this is the spot and that's
kinda I think what resonated with him
for an under recruited guy he had
instant stardom yeah which is like rare
that
happens it chooses mental makeup you
think that why he's already he's over
exceeded expectations by a mile already
and he's not even in the NFL he and
physically - it helped where he came in
and like they're whispering about like
this New Jersey freshman in the weight
room who's doing crazy [ __ ] like so it's
like they came in and like yeah like in
the first scrimmage he's you know
running through the defense in the
second scream and she's taking a screen
pass to Tiger like these stories of the
guys who were like okay like he he
emerged vast and then all of a sudden
what 19 hundred yards as a freshman
start a little slow so it's like this is
the kind of spot you can do that like
that's not gonna work in Alabama right
you know I mean like this is the caliber
you're gonna share carrots with for the
running back didn't happen annachi
Harris good two years ago and lash and
but here they had another great running
back though
let's find their guy and then all of a
sudden I know Wisconsin like they wanted
him so bad like even though nobody else
did they were like this dude can be the
guy so I think you come in you run
through a defense a couple of times it's
like alright here's 25 years there's a
marching band
this is rockin down the straight Rock
banners yes
that's authentic though yeah I'm doing
it in the real background of Wisconsin
who's your prediction for today I like
look at this right I think I just got
hit with a drum stand no I think it's I
think it'll be low-scoring I think
people are selling Michigan a little
early
truly I mean get close with the army
look at Oklahoma last year it's kind of
a gnarly game
they gotta change that offense though
it's so gross so bad but I think
Wisconsin Peaks one out the line is one
three three and a half I think it'll be
right about there yeah that's why we've
decided we're not betting on this game I
know you hear the holy spread I'm
attacking today is this Birds cheese
yeah product innovation bro let me keep
Melo around right there
bodyguard and he's good with the
marketing content it's amazing what are
you working on next I've got a lane
kiffin story and all really fantastic
eye we're talking a little bit last
night over beers which is the only way
to talk about Lane Kiffin stories it's
like a side of a coach that you don't
often see a guy that I think's a little
misunderstood so I'm excited about that
and then Jared Lorenzen which this just
got approved
I can't wait to time like dive into his
legacy right out of a different story we
get the monotony of the season guy who's
like a cult hero if he was playing now
imagine like how huge it was huh baby oh
my god so right so yeah man bunch of
different things will be flying around
doing some stuff hopefully coming yeah
we do know your mom talk to her and make
this happen
dude thank you for hanging out let's get
some beers yes Ahmir that sounds good
here
you'll definitely be a repeat guest
until you get your own podcast and then
hopefully you'll have each of us on I'm
cool with this man geez and you guys and
beers and fans let's do it right a lot
of bees here all right we'll be right
back with some live draft on draft
featuring be noted stick to Football
Hall of Fame it is draft on draft time I
can't believe I didn't somehow get a
beer during the break to open when I
said that there are a lot of people here
we're gonna bring through some
rapid-fire questions today kicking it
off with arm and an altar in a Baker
Mayfield t-shirt what's up y'all as you
know I am dan dan dan dan dan do you
know like that it's a great username so
quick question we're watching Ohio State
so far and they look [ __ ] amazing
what are some keys for them to stay on
this pace and what do you think would
stop them from what they're doing right
now I don't think any one of the big
tent can stop them it would just take
Justin Fields finally slipping up and I
will say like if there is a I don't know
that there's a weakness but if there's a
weakness it's the offensive line because
the front seven is great obviously the
secondary is amazing the wide receivers
have stepped up so well to replace scary
Terry and Parris Campbell there's not a
whole lot of weakness depth of running
back maybe but like Dobbins has looked
good so far said what master tee come in
as Ashley best name in college football
Cassie so I think that if I were a
defensive coordinator I might just say
you know what we're gonna blitz the hell
out of Justin fields we know they can
run the ball if we sit back he's gonna
tear us apart ID blitz the hell out of
him see what's gonna happen because
you're probably not gonna stop him you
just need to slow him down I think
that's your best chance there's so much
depth there but if they did lose a
running back maybe Justin Fields gets
injured
I honestly think that's the only thing
that can stop as long as they stay
healthy they go as far as Justin fields
can take them and I don't just mean
within the big ten I mean that right the
title kind of no they should be in the
playoffs
yes there's no reason this team
shouldn't be in the play the defense
looks even better I mean a coot is a
great corner they obviously have chase
young up front those linebackers can
play well and that's really inherited
you also have the second-best name in
college football tough Borland yes so
how's it play here I don't understand so
before I get off it is 9:15 Oklahoma
sucks and [ __ ] Michigan Wow all right
that was aggressive I agree it's fine
all right next up I got a mr. perfect
agenda this is a trapped on track I need
you all to settle a debate we're having
well particularly at Tyler furnace Eli
Manning will he get in the Hall of Fame
should he get in Hall of Fame I summer I
think we actually have $1,000 bet on it
I just can't remember which way I went I
think he will I think he's too big of a
name he has two Super Bowls he plays
quarterback I think those are the
requirements forgive me he will get in I
think he'll probably first second bow
the media is gonna love you like as well
and like I don't have a vote so and I'm
not trying to like you bash the people
that do but they love Eli so he's gonna
get in
follow-up question should he get in
probably not I don't think thing he's
ever really been like the top five top
ten quarterback in his career so
probably not very good we were Super
Bowls right like he made a bad throw and
David Tyree made a great catch that
Manningham throw to that was right at
the top chef Super Bowl throw up so yeah
I think he gets in I think the problem
with them getting in it kind of changes
the precedent for a hall-of-famer I mean
a lot of guys with the different resume
whether it's Super Bowl or just winning
or being part of really good teams now
have the argument to get in and snow
knock against Eli because I know we're
tough on him the last couple of years it
was a time we rely Manning it was great
for the New York Giants yeah but great
does not getting get you in the Hall of
Fame legendary I mean look at Phil Simms
same team similar situation and he's not
in but I don't get in Eli's last name
we'll get him in good question
thanks guys thanks dude Daniel Keefer
you're welcome thanks for having us I'll
bless you I'll be quick I know you're
busy and we got bears or beers or ripped
open
yeah well rip them all Matt's done it
Melo's done it it's a perfect
opportunity for one Conor Rogers Oh put
on the spot today are we getting a
sticky chug after the show can't wait
he didn't question question that was
inauthentic was come on accent yeah yeah
it kind of turned up a couple notches
for the camera have a future in this
it's like watching letter kidding all
right chair so is this game better day
in Georgia just the matchup for Julian
or Kawara for his make-or-break for his
draft stock I don't think make a break
because we know Andrew Thomas is really
really good but it is a game where
Julian oh Clark could put himself into
the second tier pass rushers no one's
touching chase young and I don't know
that it AJ FNS is pretty special too but
oh Clark could be in that you be that
next guy if he can show out today
because Andrew Thomas is in my opinion
hands down the best left tackle in the
draft class probably an all college
football honestly so it's gonna be a fun
matchup for both those guys I think we
may have heard us say this yesterday
it's appointment viewing for that that
game is because you want to see that
matchup
it's the closest you're gonna get to an
NFL matchup in the college football
season so it's big bro croire it's big
for Thomas to like though there's
pressure on him we
you know he's six five three 2004 is 265
there's a lot more athleticism there
into the season I think that for both
guys Tomas Santo Kawara this probably
gonna be the first game that I watch I
want to see how they handle each other
Marquis edge rusher gets the top tackle
probably be the first game I watch for
both guys and I think the line 14 and a
half is really disrespectful for Notre
Dame I don't care that they're on the
road I don't care how good Georgia is
when you're a top 10 team and you're
that kind of underdog so for our Quora I
mean this is a chance to make a
statement I don't know if they'll move
him around he'll see plenty of Andrew
Thomas obviously when we saw Jake from
lose to LSU last year when we were at
that game for the tailgate tour I mean
he was pressured that's how you get
after him and that's how you get up to
the Georgia offense so this is the time
for a para to really be a household name
how we doing guys good salad for Nasir
so I know Pat asked about Eli in the
Hall of Fame and that's that's the
debate that a lot of people are having
if I were to have a Hall of Fame vote
which nobody would be dumb enough to
give me I would judge it on stats impact
on the game Vanja Timothy and what I
consider most important is dominance and
that's why I would never put him in the
Hall if you were to have a Hall of Fame
boat
what would your criteria be and how
would you determine that just based on
individual players I always felt like if
I couldn't tell the story of your of the
NFL while you were playing you're not a
hall-of-famer like if so think about
like the 80s you can't talk about the
80s without talking about Joe Montana
Jerry Rice Troy Aikman Emmitt Smith the
Bears like you know Mike Singletary
Walter Payton you can't talk about that
era of football with out talk LT without
talking about those guys Darrell Green
how they change to the game so we're
like with Eli the problem is you can't
talk about two of the craziest Super
Bowls ever without talking about him
so does it does it become okay well he
was never great in season but on the
postseason in the biggest stage he was
really really good in those two games so
I think that's where that Eli is hard
for me with that criteria
I think stats you have to be smart about
that they're fluid you have to look at
the era you know dominant should come
with production so those two things
would go together for me and there was
like you said with longevity I don't
know
cause like I grow a bunch of Barry
Sanders that dude belongs the Hall of
Fame you know even though he didn't have
this to a longish career thrill Davis
Calvin Calvin Johnson we're gonna see
eventually yeah so I don't know about
about that as much and even Steve Young
you know who didn't start that many
years he was one of the greatest
quarterbacks of all time so that was not
a big one for me well I think when you
look at it when you talk about all four
of those criteria you don't have to meet
all four perfectly but if their
dominance is like a 10 out of 10
your longitudes I like a 5 out of 10
like Bernie Sanders it kind of balances
out and they don't all have to be
completely fluid but they all matter to
a certain extent if you have three out
of the four and the fourth one's pretty
good then you should probably should get
into based on my scale that's kind of
what I'm asked I think the point about
dominant it's a really good one because
whenever we have the argument over who's
the greatest tight end of all time I
always say grok because I think he's the
most dominant tight end of all time but
he is by far doesn't have the numbers
like Tony Gonzalez he doesn't have the
longevity like a lot of players but I
mean there's no one that could sit here
and say the man didn't dominate whenever
he was on the field it's a blocker and a
past catcher in a mismatch where he
changed the game just by showing up kind
of like Randy Moss that's exactly right
yeah all right thanks buddy well we got
some the cheese sample here all right so
I mean it's magnets in here I'm a noting
noted dak apologist you don't have to
apologize anymore
well Chamberlain defends Eli and Tyler
defends Kurt cousins so my question to
you guys is who's a player that you have
a soft spot for that you will defend for
at the end of time oh I don't know it's
a great question
lettuce I don't know if I have one I
don't think I do either there's got to
be something really good
okay mines college-football Texas woulda
won the national championship Colt McCoy
hadn't been hurt and I would like fight
someone like literally fight someone
over that because I think they would
have won that team wasn't stopped for if
Colt doesn't get hurt Texas Wednesday
I'll tell you who mine will be guess
we're never gonna find out if he ever
had a chance of being good Josh Rosen
that yeah and I admit that he's been bad
while also being in bad situation yes
but I'll still apologize for him because
you've been on two of the worst football
teams in the last ten years
yeah I'm with that one I don't I don't
know I don't really have one I haven't
apologized for Trent Richardson so I'm
just getting yeah yeah well [ __ ] I was
wrong my bad
I don't know that is tough I don't know
that there's a guy that I like
identifies like oh that's my guy and
there's XYZ is why he didn't work out I
can't imagine anyone defending Kirk
Cousins though that's impressive
that's like that's diehard I hope that's
the Charles Woodson signature all the
way okay alright boys so I know you guys
love Michigan's big three at wide
receiver treat black Nico Colin stock
people's Jones how you guys feel about
some of their defensive prospects Josh
Metellus levert Hill Joshua shake leak
Hudson leave some of those guys so I
think library holds the best one and we
saw have a big pick last week it was
kind of thrown right to him but yeah
it's a big play same drop one right I
think otherwise I don't have any of
those guys it's like a priority you know
like top 100 prospect right now I think
it's a little bit of a reload for
Michigan defensively especially I really
thought Runyon on the offensive line
would become a prospect maybe because of
who his dad is but we just haven't seen
that happen yet it's a lot of
improvements right now but well that's
what happens when you rebuild an entire
defense the guys got drafted so it's
wait-and-see permissions defensive but
that's why we're here today
this is you're playing against one of
the best offensive players in the
country show up today no thank you
we got one more one more maybe two more
so we'll see going it's got a couple
more quick question for you guys so I
know you guys are really high-end
DeAndre Smith of Georgia
Travis et and Clemson obviously at this
point the seasons are anyway you guys
for CJ T Jonathan Taylor for seeing are
jumping ahead of those guys as to rb1 on
the board I think so I don't think it's
I don't think it's like Oh Swift is the
best no one's touching him or a team's
my second best
I like Swift a lot but I think if let's
see what happens Swift could you get
around a four six of the combine you
know and that did change things and we
know like Kramer was saying we know JT
is gonna run well so I think what Taylor
like you know exactly what you're
getting with that dude right and I've
dug with Swift because he did share
carries that is gonna help and hurt him
because we don't know as much what he he
would have to do you know in in certain
game situations or if the you know
passing game got bogged down what is he
gonna be able to help them out so I
think Taylor is the surest thing of
those guys I brought have the most
questions about ETM Josh yeah cool
thanks I like when you guys just let me
answer
I'm from Maryland so we're just out here
having a good time yeah are you a
Maryland fan someone someone I'm just
gonna say I bet on temple last week and
you guys I'm now you've been over here
it's a god yeah every time every time
people get their hopes up on Maryland
and it's true around our house too
that's exactly what you do yeah we get
it
I have a question for you guys so with
with Manny Diaz and you know all the
recruiting going on in my head
you officially back no not you uh not
yet but on their way to get it's the
right direction yeah I mean the players
love the guy I think home recruit the
hell out of Florida which is the most
important thing for the you yeah and
it's about the France Michigan got their
brand back with Jordan with horrible all
those things Miami slowly working on
that too to be a household brand again
Miami we talked to you know they got
Antrel Rolle Santana Moss talked to them
about it
Clinton Portis they all said the same
thing like Miami for might be to be back
they have to win and that's the key it
doesn't matter as a Texas fan it truly
does not matter how many four and five
stars you get until you win and it's
like are we back no we're not you guys
kick the [ __ ] out of us for two years
there I just lost to LSU which is a good
program but you're not back until you in
it doesn't matter how many recruiting
battles you win until you get that
product on the field of my opinion that
is officially our show starting to rain
so we got to pack up but thank you again
to Jordan's big ten this place is
fantastic definitely recommend for
anyone who's going to be in the Madison
Wisconsin area Thank You getting marks
our sponsor for today's show I can't
wait to dig I'm really gonna eat were
very bright actually about the truck
yeah we're about to try once again we're
gonna try the cheese can be fun from L
O'Connor this is Matt we will be back
Wednesday morning with a regular show
Conor and I break it down the week the
was palpable in the NFL then we'll be
back Friday morning as always the three
of us so thanks for hanging out with us
guys